oi boa tarde você está convosco e para
partilhar algumas ideias deste contexto
tudo ou nada dos atuais desafios da
universidade é nós estamos no século do
conhecimento e iluminado saco do
conhecimento e da democratização do
conhecimento e portanto tem o filme teu
para o para o representar e supostamente
o saco do conhecimento devia ser o
espetáculo que está com duas velocidades
que são as causas do conhecimento no
entanto a democratização do conhecimento
o conhecimento estado é possível longe
do modo muito fácil em outros sítios não
precisamos de uma biblioteca te
encontrar nos aquilo que dentes que são
uma biblioteca que encontrávamos cria
uma situação paradoxal que pode por um
lado tirar residencial
bom e porque há coisas que dentro da
universidade quem é que neste momento se
passaram encontrar sobretudo em espaços
em espaços virtuais em dispositivos
eletrônicos portanto o que dá a planta
um desafio tá pronto um desafio
inventados adaptados já o teve muitas
vezes ao longo da sua história e é nesse
contexto que de facto vou colocar aqui
algumas ideias convosco porque portanto
nós podemos ter uma situação que as
necessidades um certamente muitas e
muitas felicidades do mundo vão perceber
que vão ser centros de enorme
importância outras e muitas delas também
provavelmente não se tornar irrelevante
vamos desaparecer pênis te importante
que tudo está prestes a última por um
movimento que está acontecendo ao
chamamos é transformação digital usando
esta analogia dos cinco dedos da mão
expiram mais ou menos cinco tecnologias
que estão enquadrados numa análise
simplista mas de facto a principal
questão é informação nos dados do
a mãe da internet das coisas vida
velocidade de comunicação que temos os
dados até hoje é muito levar em um
futuro próximo os tipos e vai ser muito
mais usada e essa quantidade enorme de
dados quantidade de informação que nós
por exemplo temos também na nossa
memória adequadamente trabalhada e
adequadamente trabalhada em
supercomputadores em máquinas que
ninguém capacidade de cálculo de podem
curar tudo aquilo que cacheado lá
inteligência de dados o as sociedades e
depois da inteligência artificial e até
ser uma área de grande importância e que
condiciona pelos vistos em movimentos
turísticos e depois com impactos
nomeadamente de robótica ou na
digitalização no fabrico digital e
impressão 3d 47 capacidade que temos de
materializar uma imagem que está
digitalizada robótica também muito
graças a inteligência artificial e toda
a questão ligada à criação da nova
realidade realidade virtual realidade
aumentada que fizeram todo um conjunto
de possibilidades e um conjunto de
diferentes inter
e as máquinas computadorizadas
certamente são as principais principais
júlio de construção desta transformação
que está a acontecer na inteligência
artificial tem uma força tem uma força
enorme sobretudo porque vem importante
os meus vai certamente ser muito mais
importantes no futuro tal como nós
fazemos temos de sair da inteligência
temos memória portanto com dados e
capacidade e inteligência conseguimos
portanto tomar decisões pensar em sua
inteligência artificial faz depois de
paulo com algoritmos muito muito débeis
muito primários muito básicos estava à
custa de grande capacidade de
comunicação que começa as máquinas
estudam e trabalham 24 horas por dia
estão sempre aprender e os objetos que a
gente misturadão no futuro é apesar de
nós já temos alguns com mais de 50 anos
deste tipo social da inteligência
artificial mas não em grande fase de
medicamentos conhecidamente podemos
chegar estamos no na emergência no no
início de uma época
o que os próprios algoritmos próprios
programas são capazes eles próprios de
altura adaptarem irem aprendendo irem
durante portanto que este é uma porta
que se abre que vai certamente criar um
mundo novo e uma sociedade não tem
implicações na sociedade em todo lar e
na indústria na medicina na agricultura
de portugal na final nas redes sociais
está vendo este turno toda a gente longe
de vidro com ele começa a questão
importante o impacto é absolutamente
tempo é absolutamente nada mas esta
transformação portanto que tá apertar
universidades empresas todos nós os
funcionários e é com certeza motivado
por tecnologias como o dinheiro dela mas
a mais do que tudo é uma mudança dos
paradigmas teria que resolver aqui
exatamente o que desde logo o paradigma
da interface humano máquina e nós muito
provavelmente o futuro próximo falaremos
pelo computador que vivemos para o
automóvel representou o que é mediação
os temas interessantes serão totalmente
diferente em vez de outros colegas
daremos lentes de
o óculos simples que eu tenho procura
provavelmente um aqui a projeção de
imagens da presente que vendem um dos
dispositivos de virtual esse o tamanho
um grande um grande impacto na economia
porque toda esta questão está apertar os
modelos de negócio da da economia
estudados são conhecidas já há dez anos
atrás das principais empresas do mundo
batista super muito ligadas à construção
ligadas a petroquímica dez anos depois
em mil em 2018 instalar uma empresa está
lá em vector mobile mas lá no fundo está
instalado a empresa ligada à saúde mas
todas as outras empresas que empresas de
tecnologia do do digital porque porque é
pacto digital que é aqui hoje está o
valor aceleração do valor e portanto
tudo isto obriga a novos posicionamentos
que as empresas que a instituição a
dimensão social será escusado falar tipo
de trabalho tipo de
e vai mudar e por que toda organização
social certamente vai ter uma enorme
mudança provocando enormes desafios
sobre sistemas com mais segurança e
aulas como o todo o padrão de reformas
um país porque vamos substituir o
trabalho por robôs e isso certamente vai
acontecer porque por mais que nós não
temos as tecnologias nenhum de nós quer
que nós os nossos filhos faça trabalhos
repetitivos faça trabalhos industriais
durante milhares de anos ou foram as
foram feitos pelo teu pelos homens e
pelas mulheres e portanto apartamento é
neste caminho que vamos agora até onde
vamos aqui onde é que estas máquinas vão
andar esse é o grande desafio desafio
que temos nunca esquecer tudo isso
acontece no mundo está em risco no mundo
que consome mais do que aquilo que tem
capacidade de regenerar e portanto
qualquer solução tecnológica qualquer
instituição com responsabilidade como
uma universidade tem que ter a
consciência de que este é talvez o
desafio
nós podemos ter uma tecnologia
fantástica mas podemos entretanto nos
próximos anos dar cabo do do planeta
porque só temos este podemos ir para
marte e vai ficar difícil mas mesmo
assim não vai ser muito bom dia lá e
portanto este planeta tempo de trocar
esse pode até podemos conservar e por
dentro da tecnologia digital tempo
também por vir a fazer para isso para
agravar esta história toda para as
universidades que são normalmente ou
supostamente instituições muitos
ponderável mas por isso doentes nos
processos de decisão mas também para as
empresas para as instituições tudo isto
acontece cada vez mais rapidamente a
palavra estava floração acontece porque
é uma aceleração da tecnologia mas a uma
aceleração dos processos importantes as
instituições para todas as refeições
mais pesadas como tenha sempre
dificuldade em responder isto e
importante estamos aqui muito branco não
sei não hoje trabalhamos a 10 megabytes
um importante que nós estamos de 4
15 jogarmos realmente às vezes é os
nossos cálculos de supercomputação ainda
estão ainda estão no pé tem que estar
alerta porque 10:18 flocos irão
brevemente para o década de 50 que é uma
felicidade enorme que essas coisas
ficaram isso faz com que as instituições
têm a ser deputado usar no caso das
sociedades mudar rapidamente o seu
currículo fazer adaptações do modo como
são as suas diferentes culturas e também
uma questão que diz muito do ponto de
vista laboratorial das pessoas da
miniaturização importante entre a pouco
tempo estava a ver nada a tecnologia
hoje a caminhos cobertura ciência
quântica falamos cada vez mais um
pequeno frente importante não deve -
novos tratamentos todos os casamentos
que ao mais sem lógicas muito fortes
estão acontecer isso causa com que os
desafios das instituições são cada vez
mais difícil
e portanto mais do que tudo essa
transformação digital com certeza volta
dizer a tecnologia mas é também modos
diferentes de pensar apesar tudo e agora
vindo mais concretamente para a
engenharia para e para as tecnologias e
tudo o que aconteceu e tudo que
aconteceu no século 20 que os
computadores depois da segunda guerra
mundial mas não cena pensamos a partir
de uma de uma física newtoniano apareceu
pensamos a partir de um continuar e
pretende o teu não temos lado assentadas
na cabeça mas é praticamente algo
semelhante a isto o nosso modo de pensar
que foi e funções muito significativas
nas o paradigma de pensamento então para
ver como é que vem da revolução da
revolução científica do século xvii
século 17 e 18 e portanto tem sobre o
tempo e tem informação digital e
sobretudo passar por um quadro mais
analítico um quadro de precisão marise
informal e quadro de conexão de
interações muito maior
a picture aumentar complexo temático
danos autor vários autores hoje dizem
que estamos numa revolução científica
dizendo que estamos no momento de criar
e construir uma nova ideia sobre sobre o
mundo porque o espaço integral além da
transformação digital e começou a falar
a grandes transformações do lado de
materiais materiais que são inteligentes
eles próprios são capazes de alterar em
alta corante do biotech do lado da da
biotecnologia das ciências da vida e
sobretudo hoje somos capazes de evitar a
vida somos capazes de manipular a vida e
portanto de fazer medições elétricas do
que o algo muito incentivo certamente
muito perigoso estamos no advento da
ciência quântica passar a tecnologia
quântica alto duplo tá mentindo normas
da computação e dar também são
absolutamente enormes na
a herança mas também na metrologia nas
comunicações e pretende mas como tudo o
quanto é a parte carnosa ficar
totalmente cotação do mundo não
partícula não continuo como o tratamos
hoje estamos com as coisas vão continuar
cês tão sólidas líquidas ou gasosas e
ter uma intervenção do mundo e da
realidade física uma opção partículas
partículas que tem mais ou menos
densidade quando estão num sítio outro
portanto este é o contexto contexto
muito complexo em que as universidades
têm um contas que está incluído muito
rapidamente que dias de muita capacidade
de mudança e adaptação mas que existe
também é importante estratégia para
vencer esse desafio por tempo associada
estão enorme cruzamento de tecnologia e
de realidades e domingos desde logo a
sobreposição do virtual como no real à
medida que no dia que tivermos um uma
interpretação do dispositivo capaz de
colocar nos meus óculos aqui imagem
a classe trazer o real em cima do
virtual em cima do real e vou ter
certamente uma nova apreensão da
realidade quem cresça inácio na
sequência nesse mundo certamente vai ter
maria do mundo diferente daquela que nós
temos temos dá uma mistura total dentro
da engenharia entre realidade física ea
saúde dos sistemas de informação e a
realidade a fibra ótica de que estamos o
sistema estiver físicos e temos uma
aplicação de norma da tecnologia no mano
não sei bem como é que vai ser uma
espécie de uma caixa de junção não
devemos nada por um fio direito em
controlado por um dinheiro mas isso vai
acontecer e nós vamos ligar já hoje
fazemos os ovos um de cada vez mais
ligar almas a marca homens e mulheres
máquinas e portanto a ligação do humano
e este sistema informático que vai
também acontecer e de cacto nós dois
falamos na internet das coisas mas cada
vez mais falaremos no futuro na internet
da oi
as pessoas cria apreensões queria estar
com a mente sorteios em dificuldade de
toda a prefeitura nós próprios e
principal tem muito importante pra muito
importante para as universidades
funcionarem praticarem discutirem é
certamente as questões assistindo
técnicas nomeadamente por toda a
seguinte ligadas às ciências da vida e a
e a manipulação de vida à privacidade à
informação a segurança portanto estão
enormes ativo um desafio que é muito
maior que aquilo que aparentemente
podemos pensar é porque esta vai ter que
ser uma época também então nem humanos e
máquinas porque as máquinas também vão
tomar decisões e a provavelmente aqui
que vai estar o grande debate do grande
debate político e não tenho dúvidas que
dentro de 48 anos nas eleições vamos ter
que o debate político de partidos os
limites onde é que vão onde é que vai a
tecnologia onde é que vão as máquinas
até que as máquinas podem fazer o que é
que podem impedir o que é que podem
pensar e para as
e eu com isso aqui o tamanho da pessoa
capaz de ensinar neste ser capaz de
criar cidadãos e afinar cidadãos que
tenham essa capacidade de pensamento e
esse pensamento crítico e esse é esse
nível assim tentando concluir a partir
deste mundo que muito importante
tratamento poderá ser muito desafiante é
muito complexo sem dúvida gostava de vos
dizer que as universidades que um
parente desafios e novos contatos
partilháveis por forças por força
portanto que entenderam aguentar por um
hábito do contexto político ao
regulamentar todas as questões do quadro
legal dos portões dos financiamentos das
propinas que tem montanhas recebem em
paga portanto a todo um contexto que se
enquadra aos necessitados e que é
diferente do país de país para país a
uma crescente concorrência internacional
também nacional e uma conversa entre o
filme confesso que também cada vez mais
é feita como espaços como o espaço
a unidade que o próximo aquilo que
algumas universidades oferecem
fisicamente mas que oferecem espaços
nádia às vezes o melhor por qualidade do
que do que o que as universidades
tradicionais o carinho que temos por
algo muito importante as duas cidades
terão que responder aos grandes desafios
sociais ou perto cada vez mais a
sociedade deve ter que te ajude cidades
respondem respondam aos desafios sociais
e as universidades tem que ter que era
agentes dessa transformação digital
quero entendê-la e ser proativos por
dizer é preciso de facto a tecnologia
aqui as envolventes que passaste o
também uma não entendimento social que é
que está a passar uma nova interpretação
da sociedade sem ser feito porque as
universidades tem que fazer e estiver um
quadro de grande complexidade como cê
quase de algumas de alguns objetivos
conflito al213 cidades terão que
responder e por isso mencionados se
quiserem sobreviver se quiserem por ser
se não quiserem desenhar e tornar-se
se transformou tudo fazer opções fazer
opções do seu posicionamento foram ter
estratégia qualquer coisa importante
serão sobretudo se diferenciarem
afirmarem-se nesse contexto entram
sempre está centrada no estudante todas
as mais estou não pode ser um não pode
ser mais uma frase de retórica ea partir
daqui que a universidade monta mas faz
muitas mais coisas tem que fazer muitas
mais coisas mas tem que estar sempre
aqui da presidência todas as
universidades preocupada com a questão
ecológica e de sustentabilidade e
conectadas mas algumas tratamento bem
acentuar acentuar esta questão outras
foram as chamadas diversidade de quartas
a sangue as velocidades são parlamento
proativos no meio de um caso motores da
economia depende muito do ecossistema em
que as universidades estão e do mal
começou a social não com esse meio mas
pode ser um caminho a grau necessidade
para um praticamente formação ao longo
da vida formação à medida muito utilizar
e para um praticamente os carros
é o virtual e haverá a universidade se
forem tentados disso que serão um centro
de investigação de grande de grande
potência mundial e procura dão ter toda
a sua sua afirmação à custa de uma
investigação de faça a diferença o que é
também um desafio muito muito importante
então modelos do que pode ser uma
universidade e que certamente entre as
por eles têm todas as situações vividas
possíveis aquilo que gostaria dizer que
a partilhar que eu gosto é que mais do
que tudo mais do que não ao modelo com o
ideal onde está a tem que saber onde
quer estar um pé posicionado e vai ter
que ter uma estratégia para se poder
reinventar depois de felicidade ser só
longo dos tempos fez de fé sempre que
teve revoluções por vezes ando atrás de
avaliações para ver se foi a dentro do
opções mas é isto que eu disse ah tem
que fazer para se reinventar e para ser
uma entidade
a pousada da factory sem proativo da
construção desse futuro que alguns de
nós como eu acreditamos que vai ser
muito importante muito potente muito
obrigado a
e aí